[Applause]
[Music]
sebastián piñera is already president
well actually he's president again
because as you all know this political
leader was president of Chile barely two
mandates ago between 2010 and 2014
[Music]
now after retrieving a strong and
healthy victory by almost 10 points in
the 2017 presidential elections last Ian
Pinero was declared president on March
the 11th
[Music]
well if you were in this video today we
are going to be seeing what kinds of
Chile this president is inheriting as
well as the great challenges that lie
ahead for him but first of all let's get
to know this character better let's see
whose sebastián piñera
really is
[Music]
who is Sebastian Pinera
first of all we need to know that
Sebastian Pinera for many reasons isn't
just another politician musi we're
talking about a man who on the one hand
owns one of the biggest fortunes in
Chile per fortune the Forbes magazine
estimates is no less than two point
seven billion dollars yep you heard that
right
yo siempre murarilal contra kok killin
apart our delgrovia LAPD to brenda rote
memory state on observe o.k prefer a new
movie n mo en ole opera or a politico's
eva co emprender a son esto que lo
primero puede poner a todo y los Segundo
inada
[Music]
for years Sebastian Pinera was an
aggressive self-made businessman but do
not be fooled by his Colgate smile his
record shows that for a long time
Panera knew how to play to the limit and
become a major investor in various
sectors such as construction
supermarkets Airlines and TV channels
yeah I mean now that I think about it
it's really hard to find a sector in
which Pinero didn't try his luck even in
2006 he decided to bet on the football
industry and took control of a team but
not just any team nope he took control
of the most important soccer team in
Chile collar collar of course many
critics accuse him of buying this team
not as an investment but as a political
maneuver like Silvio Berlusconi but
don't think that Panera's exploits were
only in the business sector not at all
in fact in the political arena the
current President of Chile also left his
mark in 2010 he became the first
right-wing president to be
democratically elected since 1958 panera
also became the first right-wing
president since Chile underwent its
democratic transition after Augusto
Pinochet's era
now in 2018 this is happening again in
other words we could say that sebastián
piñera there's a pretty fortunate guy
and I don't think you'd disagree well
the fact is that in his first term
despite having to face the consequences
of a terrible earthquake that shook his
country just two weeks before he took
office his first government had
relatively good results at least half of
our efforts throughout the entire
administration were devoted to
rebuilding the country and consequently
we had to sacrifice many things we
wanted to do
Rodrigo hints Peter Minister of the
Interior and Minister of Defense in
Sebastian pinatas first government the
truth is that no great revolutionary
change really happens however in his
first four years of government the
economy grew by more than 5% per year
more than 1 million jobs were created
wages increased and poverty fell sharply
we had a really good government in which
every social and economic indicator
improved in Chile but I have more
experience now and experience counts
sebastian pinata and the truth is to
view it that in this case all that
experience can be really really
important then why is this well because
today Chile is really quite different
I mean pay attention to this
[Music]
[Applause]
today's chilly
we already told you here on visual
politic previously and I don't think it
will surprise anyone that in the last
few decades Chile has been something
like Latin America's Cristiano Ronaldo
the country that grew the most the one
that had the most success convincing
proof of this was the evolution of the
Chilean middle class which multiplied by
almost three within a very short span of
time the Chilean middle class grew from
23.7% to sixty four point three percent
of the population in 25 years however as
we saw in a previous video in recent
years specifically during Michelle
Bachelet last turn things really changed
Chile's on 5 may be a no que uno al
canceled pre no es Arroyo pero su
Buzzelli Radha Mohan is a she donde las
últimas vecas nan sapwe no la Frontera
bro desafío de la moneda en la atención
ekayon frente la democracia yel
crecimiento Kaname
just as we mentioned in recent years
economic growth has plummeted job
creation has slowed wages having grown
and foreign investment has dropped
lately the only thing that has grown in
Chile has been the number of public
employees taxes and bureaucracy
that's right practically every economic
parameter made a very negative change
during michelle bachelet last term I
mean check this out
there has been an average growth of
barely 1.8% per year which implies that
this legislation was the worst economic
growth since the democratic transition
in fact in recent years Chile has grown
a less than the world economy and
considerably less than its Pacific
Alliance counterparts Mexico Peru and
Colombia and that's not all the public
deficit went from being a guest to a
permanent tenant and of course that
certainly has consequences
public debt although still low has
reached its highest level since 1993
having the fiscal debt double every four
years isn't sustainable that's the road
to the precipice Philippe Loraine
Minister of Finance although by far the
worst development has been the four-year
consecutive drop in investments and it
wasn't only the economy that went south
crime rates have increased a lot in the
Erica near region where there's a
conflict with the indigenous people the
mapuches who demands more autonomy and
recognition violent acts have exploded
growing by a hundred and fifty percent
[Music]
yellow Sudan o tengan colonies are
militias are mahaprabhu taker say okay
Deven tomar la Justicia por su propia
Manos
and even regarding health the
government's decision to suspends the
hospital concession system has meant
that the government has barely been able
to invest more than half of what they're
budgeted making wait lists and quality
issues a chronic problem and let's not
deceive ourselves here as always the
ones most affected by all of this are
not the richest but the middle class and
even more so the most vulnerable people
in the population the poor people in
other words is fair to say that Chileans
have no reason to celebrate McHale bash
chalets last term indeed they were an
incredibly intense for years now perhaps
we could better analyze what's happening
initially by taking a look at their
economic Freedom Index whose correlation
with a country's level of wealth and
prosperity is very high well during
Mikkel - chalets last term Chile fell
from 7th position to 20th anyway this is
the situation that the new presidents of
Chile has to face and now the question
we need to ask ourselves is what should
this new government's priorities be what
can we expect what should we expect from
them well let's take a look at that
tenemos que hacer que el fallo Anasuya
covetous we're not gonna go here Catina
Chilean thank God you know dinner
civilian dr. Kenneth crear sino que
incluye no bueno said brain ANOVA for
Anoka lado de la cancion
[Music]
they're great challenges well it seems
quite clear vers in a country that isn't
exactly cheap and in which three out of
four workers make less than $800 a month
the economy has to be then number one
priority if the economy isn't doing well
social statistics won't do well either
and this seems to be very very clear for
the new government in fact panera the
new president has promised to focus his
efforts on doubling economic growth
creating hundreds of jobs since laying
the foundations for Chile to become the
first developed country in Latin America
by 2025
but of course you might be thinking how
on earth can they achieve this I hope he
doesn't think that a mere tax reform is
going to be enough to restore Chile's
growth he is going to need an aggressive
policy to stimulate diversification
almost half of the country's exports are
still copper Ricardo Hausmann well to
achieve the 2025 goal the country needs
to deal with three very player
priorities diversify their economy
improve their productivity and adjust
their public accounts but do not think
that this is an easy task do you
diversify the economy to stop relying on
raw materials especially copper and
boost their productivity Panera's Chile
will need a few things first they will
need to promote investment especially
foreign investment that is attract more
companies and foreign capital who will
bet on Chile to produce and provide
services this plan could really be
helped by a reversal of bachelors
terrible tax reform which not only
raised taxes on companies but also
punished their investments this was
really not a good idea further they
should decrease the huge bureaucracy
that exists for example by digitizing
every possible process seconds and this
is a much more controversial issue for
this latin-american country they need to
promote a program to attract foreign
talent yeah they really need to be
promoting immigration you see in Chile
the immigrant population has grown a lot
in recent years but it's still very low
and hasn't even reached three percent of
the population and Chileans like to
compare themselves with Australia and
New Zealand where immigrants make up 30%
of the total population ten times more
than they do in Chile yes you really did
hear that right and the best way to gain
talent and promote different businesses
and activities is to attract people with
different skills and abilities from all
over the world
we're actually going to be discussing
that in more detail really soon but for
now here's a great example in Silicon
Valley the great global Innovation
Center 54% of entrepreneurs are
foreigners and though we're not talking
about an open door but we are talking
about setting up a mechanism that
clarifies and promotes talent attraction
because well at the end of the day if it
all goes well
Chile can aspire to become the great
benchmark for business in Latin America
and that implies attracting
professionals
in addition and this is an important
detail according to all Chilean
standards immigrants have more education
on average their labor participation is
much higher and they even earn more
money other policies Chile needs to
enforce our improving relations between
universities and companies fighting
insecurity and ending the public deficit
as well as improving infrastructure and
increasing savings so now if we take a
look at Panera's program we will see
that the president's promises seem to
align with this so in principle his
political change is going to be really
good for Chile now of course as always
only time will tell but just hold on a
moment because not everything is quite
so simple so due to an electoral reform
that bascially promoted Panera's
coalition doesn't have a majority in
congress so negotiating and seeking
parliamentary agreements will be a
priority for this new governmental team
so Divya that's the way things are in
Chile today but now it's your turn
what's your opinion on Sebastian
Panera's new government do you think his
government will be good for Chile well
leave your answer in the comment section
below as well as in this survey and I
really hope you did enjoy this video
please do hit that like button if you
did and do not forget to subscribe
because we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday also
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine and as always thanks for
watching
the name of Justin trapped in a thong
I'm Akira technology you know dinner -
Beatrice you're a nucleus it okay
they're true you know where does that
play in of a forum of Milano's